[Musik]
hallo meine lieben willkommen zu einem
neuen blog von mir aus belgien befinde
mich gerade in brüssel wir sind vor
ungefähr einer stunde angekommen kann
das natürlich auch mit dabei
ich bin ja wir haben es auch mit dabei
wir sind hier zusammen mit magnum wir
dürfen morgens zum chocolatier barry
callebaut und alle hobby bäcker becker
den rassen grad bestimmen auch callebaut
ist so die leckerste schokolade die ich
kenne also jeder der gerne backt hat
schon mal mit callebaut schokolade zu
tun gehabt da bin ich mir ganz sicher
wir gucken uns morgen nämlich smuggling
ruby an ruby schokolade das ist sehr
diffus und genau die rosa die vierte
schokoladen wusstest du dass die ersten
drei kam und rubens die väter
schokoladen abdi wurde jahr 2017
entdeckt ich will sowieso gold oder
silber ja also ich liebe sowie
schokolade weil die so einen fruchtigen
geschmack aber ich glaub ja gar nicht
viel drumherum wir schauen uns das ja
morgen gemeinsam an heute werden wir
noch den tag nutzen gingen doch ich so
ein bisschen draußen abend noch ein
schönes abendessen wir nehmen euch auf
jeden fall mit
[Musik]
jetzt damit ausgeruht umgezogen und
jetzt gehts aber schauen wir noch so
dabei ist du warst heute daniel dabei
ist der junk food co
die vergeht bis zum abendessen und ich
habe mir auch schon richtig hunger da
gibt's ab jetzt
[Musik]
jürgen trittin
so wieder zurück auf dem zimmer das war
ein richtig schönes abendessen richtig
schönes kennenlernen auch mit den
anderen total entspannt als freue ich
mich einfach wahnsinnig auf morgen
morgen sind wir bei callebaut in der
schokoladenfabrik kiki in der
schokoladenfabrik also so als wären ein
traum wahr werden würde ich freue mich
auf jeden fall extrem ich mache jetzt
noch ein bisschen was am pc ich werde
jetzt noch so ein bisschen meinen
aktuellen blog schneiden und dann lege
ich mich auch ins gemütliche bett und
werde einfach nur mein schlaf nachholen
damit ich morgen auch fit bin und dann
nehme ich euch morgen natürlich fleißig
mit also gute nacht und bis muskeln
[Musik]
okay wir sind angekommen
doch die natürliche schokolade die wurde
2017 erste becken heute tritt als umso
geschossen hatte und die wird nicht
extra rosa gefärbten alles natürlich
keine psychischen stoffe und der
geschmack ist über alle die es so nie
probiert haben
das hat sich schon mit ruby folge
schlecker hat dich jetzt erst mal einen
buben denken wir tun
[Musik]
am 1
starke die stark
[Musik]
nein
und das ist daraus entstanden hier
unseren genug komplett spielen und oben
ist noch eine junge himmel
diese geräusche machen geräusche richtig
lecker
probier's mal mit dem
der joghurt
[Musik]
den boden total krank
natürlich ruby schokolade joghurt und
sahne
[Musik]
hier geht es dabei aber kompakte daran
dass sich bayer dann richtig cool
ja mut zur farbe ich feiere das sehr
cool mit dem golden girls
wer liebt sie nicht so hier haben wir
die movie kakaobohne sitze im innern aus
ein langer prozess die wächst vier
monate die wird erst kommentiert
aussortiert getrocknet zu kaunitz
verarbeitet hammer und nur durch diesen
prozess schmeckt die so gut schmeckt
fruchtig schmeckt sehr natürlich hat so
ein kleines und zitrus geschmack müsst
ihr unbedingt probieren oder ihr
probiert direkt mubi
ich habe euch nicht mitnehmen
[Musik]
die führung durch die fabrik war mega
spannend mit film aber für mich
persönlich war das mega mega spannend zu
sehen und ist im bereich marken kreieren
und ich werde jetzt stehen und ich hoffe
mal dass ein kunde wunderschön animiert
[Musik]
nein
freie bürger
[Musik]
die hoch
denn so ganz frisch
jetzt nehme ich mir mein selbst macht
das magnum movie und geht zu den foto
boxen richtig cool kann man sich eine
von drei fotos aussuchen was man so
richtig cool das aussieht sagt daniel
[Gelächter]
selbst stimmt bitte mal ab in den
kommentaren welches als würdet ihr stimm
das größte
natürlich ist das haben sie es kreation
und das meine ich ehrlich koma diese
blaubeere das tun und diese bildnisse
mal dass uns beide
das ist ja schon wieder sie ja von mir
mich eigentlich der meinung dass liebe
gewinnt enorm
ihr dürft gerne in die kommentare
schreiben wie ihr dann steht ja ich
glaube
[Musik]
am 1
wir sind wieder zu hause es ist jetzt
kurz vor elf ich nochmal gleich noch ein
leckeres eis komplett und nicht duschen
und ab ins bett aber ich hoffe natürlich
dass euch der block gefallen hat und ich
habe schon auf instagram mitbekommen
weil ich euch parallele ein bisschen
auch über die installateurs mitgenommen
also ich das mitbekommen dass einige
gesagt haben
wahnsinn dass die ruby schokolade
einfach natürlich rosa ist und viele
abgeschrieben ich dachte immer dass der
weiße schokolade die rosa gefärbt ist
aber das ist gar nicht so daher wagt es
ruhig mal probiert wo die schokolade
probiert das moby und ja wie gesagt
lasst uns gerne in den kommentaren
austauschen sowie unter jedem block da
freue ich mich besonders für kommentare
und ansonsten sehen wir uns entweder
beim nächsten rezept video oder bei
meinem nächsten block bis bald
ach ja und ihr müsst diesem video in
dörflichen nach oben dann lassen wir es
euch gefallen hat und natürlich meinen
kanal kostenlos abonnieren dann schon
fast ihr so coole blogs auch nicht mehr
weiter